police in the summer governor sisilak
appointed barbara buckley to lead the
unemployment rapid response task force
the goal was to help tackle
a number of problems the department had
faced with the unprecedented amount of
claims today
it was announced she will no longer be
in that volunteer role
joe mohler live over at dieter with more
on that and updates she provided
joe well brian she was in that role for
around five months much longer than they
anticipated
she would be now she provided
recommendations for the department
moving forward while also addressing a
number of
issues that people continue to face
by december 31st 1.5
million claims were filed thursday deter
announced the rapid response strike
force leader barbara buckley will no
longer be helping the department when
the strike force began
there were 245
765 claims in the backlog
thousands of claims still remain in the
backlog with the current processing rate
of
5 000 a week the welfare staff can clear
this remainder by february 7th
thousands are still waiting to have
their appeals heard as well something
they say they are getting through and
adding 10 staff to help
next week take the week of january 11th
723 appeals were reviewed
568 were either redetermined
and paid the appeal was withdrawn
or if it was or it was determined not to
be a valid appeal
leaving 155 to be scheduled
when the extension of benefits was added
many people were left without their
money
the department is working on what
extension comes first we are still
working out with the department of labor
what the sequence is
of how you get your p e u c
weeks and then go to state extended
benefit weeks
because we have to get the order right
dieter is updating computer programs
working on
phone problems and implementing new
fraud fighting tools
the director says they know many are
falling victim to fraud especially with
the bank of america debit cards
she says every day they send claims to
the bank to be reinstated
but the bank is now behind we are
working on
resolving that um and my understanding
right now is that bank of america does
have a backlog
in terms of unfreezing cards
and the director says another goal
moving forward is to get people back to
work that's something they are working
on if you wanted to check out that
entire press conference it is up on our
facebook page
on eight news now page that is reporting
live here at the dealer office joe
mohler 8 news now